thank you you guys thank you for coming
hey it means a lot to me you came
Christine Brown breaks down in tears as
she says goodbye to the family and it's
not exactly the farewell she wanted I
didn't ask for like having them all come
over it was worse than I thought it
would have been right now I'm requiring
a bit of a distance to be honest with
you I feel like I'm just starting to get
to know me I really like me and I want
to keep it that way
this week's episode of Sister Wives
follows the family's explosive fight and
with Christine's move to Utah just a day
away her and Cody's daughter mckelty
brings them all together again but
things don't go the way she planned it's
awkward outside it's weird it's intense
nobody really wants to be here dad
doesn't want to be here Robin doesn't
want to be here mom doesn't want to be
here
it's weird yeah it seems they're all
feeling that way I felt it best for us
not to get in the way say anything say
goodbye or anything like that and then
mckelty called me and she was like Robin
I think it would be best if you came and
you guys came and said goodbye
this is such an awkward moment to sort
of have this family gathering and Say
Goodbye that is way off course for me
way off the charts it's not it's not
even right it's very apparent how
awkward we all are but Janelle and her
kids are on one side and Robin and Cody
are on the other
none of us want to be here and to make
it even more Awkward Robin and Cody's
daughter Ariella asks Christine this
what did you mean that break up we just
want to love anymore you know that
happens sometimes
but we'll still hang out sometimes
oh well it doesn't always fix everything
my love but thank you what a good idea
it's awkward you know when Ari's asking
why I'm leaving it's difficult but I
we're hopefully going to be fine you
know I think I was a lot more optimistic
that we would be like besties so I'm not
quite sure about that but we'll see then
as Christine thanks everyone for coming
things get emotional it means a lot to
me that came
[Music]
I wouldn't have asked for this I didn't
ask for like having them all come over
I think this was the worst goodbye
that I've ever witnessed
jump to present day and Christine's
marking a big milestone in her life I
started moving forward and I just don't
I don't I didn't look back I never
looked back I just started moving
forward the mom of six recently shared
she's filming the TLC series at her new
home in Utah I made like a promise to
like Cody and everybody else and I will
stay with Sister Wives as long as we
have the show just to be fair it's what
our family's been doing for so long and
so no I absolutely I feel like it would
be disloyal if I you know decided to not
be part of the show
[Music]
foreign